recuerda milenios de vida en la naturaleza silvestre.
Hace diez mil años,
el mundo entero era la naturaleza.
Hoy, la naturaleza es lo poco que queda de ese mundo que ya desapareció.
Hace diez mil años, éramos lo mismo que hoy:
una inteligencia moderna, soñadora, nunca antes vista.
La vida en la naturaleza nos enseñó a hablar,
a buscar técnicas como el fuego y la piedra, el arco y la flecha,
la medicina y el veneno,
a domesticar plantas y animales
y a depender unos de otros, de todos los seres que nos rodeaban.
Somos esta última naturaleza silvestre,
todos y cada uno de nosotros.
Más del 80 % de la superficie del planeta
sufre actualmente el impacto de la actividad humana:
la destrucción del hábitat y el comercio ilegal de animales
están diezmando las poblaciones silvestres del mundo.
Necesitamos urgentemente crear espacios seguros
para estos animales silvestres.
Para ello, a fines de 2014
lanzamos un ambicioso proyecto de exploración y protección.
Para mediados de mayo de 2015, habíamos abierto el acceso
a través de campos de minas activas,
al lago donde nace el río Cuito, nunca antes documentado;
un lugar mágico,
con su naturaleza intacta y ancestral.
El 21 de mayo, comenzamos el megatransecto del Okavango
en siete canoas.
Al cabo de más de 2400 km y 121 días
de remar y avanzar, y de muchas investigaciones,
cruzamos la cuenca completa del río hasta llegar al lago Xau
en el desierto del Kalahari, a 480 km del delta del Okavango.
El agua se convirtió en mi mundo:
cada onda del río, cada remolino, cada nenúfar, cada corriente,
cada señal de peligro,
cada manifestación de vida.
Imaginen millones de abejas del sudor revoloteando alrededor,
bacterias antropófagas,
el peligro permanente de que explote una mina
o un hipopótamo que dé vuelta el mokoro.
Aquí vemos el momento posterior a ese ataque:
un hipopótamo clavó los colmillos en el bote.
Allí se ven las dos perforaciones, en la base del casco.
Absolutamente aterrador,
y todo por culpa mía.
(Risas)
Mucho transporte de carga por tierra,
árboles que bloquean el camino y botes que vuelcan en los rápidos rocosos.
Nos alimentábamos de arroz y frijoles,
nos bañábamos en un balde de agua fría
y remábamos una maratón de seis a ocho horas por día.
Luego de 121 días,
había olvidado las claves de acceso a mis cuentas bancarias y redes sociales;
un verdadero reseteo del sistema.
Pregúntenme ahora si extraño aquello,
les diré que todavía estoy allí.
Pero ¿por qué salvar lugares que casi no visitamos?
¿Por qué salvar lugares donde uno arriesga su vida?
No soy particularmente religioso ni espiritual,
pero en la naturaleza,
creo haber encontrado el lugar de origen de la religión.
Estar frente a un elefante, lejos de todo lo demás,
es lo más cercano a Dios que encontraré jamás.
Moisés, Buda, Mahoma, Jesús,
los maestros, profetas y místicos hindúes
fueron todos a la naturaleza,
a las montañas, al desierto,
para contemplar en silencio y escuchar los secretos
que guiarían sus sociedades durante miles de años.
Yo voy al Okavango en mi mokoro.
Deben venir conmigo algún día.
Más del 50 % de los terrenos vírgenes que quedan está desprotegidos.
Una enorme oportunidad,
para todos nosotros.
Es necesario actuar de manera urgente.
Desde el megatransecto en 2015, hemos explorado todos los ríos principales
de la cuenca del río Okavango,
cubriendo 6430 km de transectos de investigación detallada
en nuestras canoas
y nuestras bicicletas de montaña.
En este momento hay 57 científicos de primera línea
que están redescubriendo lo que llamamos la torre de agua del Okavango-Zambezi,
esta inmensa naturaleza virgen de posguerra con lagos no documentados,
cascadas sin nombre enclavadas en el mayor bosque de miombo
que queda en África.
Hemos descubierto 24 nuevas especies para la ciencia
y cientos de especies que se desconocían en la zona.
Este año iniciamos el proceso con el gobierno de Angola
para establecer uno de los sistemas más grandes de áreas protegidas del mundo,
a fin de preservar la torre de agua del Okavango-Zambezi
que venimos explorando.
Río abajo, esto significa agua segura para millones de personas
y para más de la mitad de los elefantes que quedan en el planeta.
Sin duda esta es la mayor oportunidad para impulsar la conservación
que África haya tenido en décadas.
En los próximos 10 a 15 años,
necesitamos una inversión sin precedentes
para preservar la naturaleza virgen en todo el mundo.
Para mí,
preservar la naturaleza va más allá de la simple protección de los ecosistemas
que limpian el agua que bebemos y crean el aire que respiramos.
Preservar la naturaleza virgen
protege nuestro derecho humano a ser silvestres,
nuestro derecho humano a explorar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)